so I am I work for for continuum
analytics as Ian say
and today I would like to talk to you
about a new a new way to send data from
memory to CPU that potentially can be
faster than me mcp why it's a maybe it's
a little bit a strange why I am
emphasizing so much maincity why how
many are on you know what min CPI means
Wow okay excellent so for those of you
that doesn't know what min cpy is is
basically the system call that makes
copies from one area of memory to
another area okay so it's the fastest
way in theory to transmit to copy data
from one part of the memory to the other
one so let's see if we can beat em cpy
in doing these tasks okay so happy words
about me I am the creator of tools like
pie tables which is behind the hdf store
in pandas this very fast way to
serialize data also the main offer of a
blush on also bliss which is a new
backend for blaze which is an inter
project of continuum and as Ian set and
the current maintainer of new mex / 2
which is a way to compute expressions
very fast and pandas the latest versions
of pandas are using it too he also
learned the hard way that the premature
optimization is the root of all evil I
try very hard to not do that again and I
only hope that this my last effort doing
blush is not another example of
premature optimization so let's see also
some words about continuing our ethics
we are a company that the we are trying
while we are developing in fact new ways
to store data and the computer and
visualize data okay we provide open
technologies for data integration on a
massive scale basically big data and we
are providing software tools training
integration and consulting services to
corporate government
an educational clients worldwide so
let's go to the meat of the talk first
of all I will show you if we can
compress actually faster than mem cpy i
will show you some benchmarks then in if
this is the case how we can do that
because in theory nothing can be faster
than a memory copyright and I will
introduce the way due to disturb in CPU
problem then I will go a little bit in
deep on how blast works and I will
finish by looking at it being faster
than min cpy actually means that real
programs with real data can go faster ok
because we can do a lot of bags max ok
you know that there is lies more lies
and benchmarks but of course if that
doesn't work in real life we don't have
nothing so we are going to see a real
life example at the end so compressing
faster than mcp why now I am going to
start an interactive session with
ipython notebook ok so those of you that
want to exercise the same thing and
check by yourself in your laptop's can
be faster also then bras can be faster
than meant to be winding your laptops
you can download the materials here and
you can check your own we don't have a
lot of time because this is not a
tutorial but maybe later around you want
you may want to download that ok and
check in your own laptops for running
these notebooks you will need the block
dependency and also the BLC to the Bliss
dependency ok both are included in the
Condor repository so it's just a
condensed all blocks can be on seeds
away so let's go with them
notebook
I think presentation malt will be better
ya think so okay so we need first to
import some libraries in Python for
doing for do we know where over the
benchmark and we are going to create an
array which is 20 million 20 millions
large okay and we are going to
experiment with a compression level in
block which is six it's between it's a
medium medium conventional level its
completion levels in blocks can go from
zero to two 290 means no compression and
nine mins maximum compression and then
an end times is the number of times that
we loop in order to do time ends ok so
here we create some labels in order to
produce nice plots later on and here we
are going to to perform our first
benchmark we are checking not here the
speed of mcp why ok so maybe cpy is
accessible through Python via AC types
ok instead of calling it meant TTYL and
see types a call it may move but is the
same thing ok so we create an array of
twenty20 mineral elements made of in
eight bytes integers and also a
container for getting the results which
is out in and out okay and then we loop
on this on this mem cpy so the source is
here and the destination is here ok and
I mean cpy you need to add also the
number of lights that you are going to
copy bites ok maybe BYU's really low
level ok unfortunately i am i am using
my back book air which is pretty old I
initially I was trying to do the the
talk using this this computer which is
much more powerful but I had problems
with the with the video so i am using
that so all the numbers that you are
going to see here are made in this
bigger laptop this bigger laptop is an
intel i5 with two physical processors to
physical cores ok so the time for that
is zero dot 0 32 seconds then cpy then
in this loop it does apparently a lot of
things I am NOT going to explain
everything just that we are going to
create different data distributions ok
so we have an arranged extraversion a
range means 0 1 dot 0 1 2 3 okay then
the linear space which is an evenly
distributed data set between value value
0 and 1000 with 10 million elements to
and then p really random distribution to
with values between 0 and 2000 1000
sorry then blast supports many different
compressors actually currently it
supports just for compressors man maybe
in the future we will support more so we
loop on all each of the compressor that
block supports and then we do another
loop for checking the time for
compressing okay and the time also for
the compressing here plus dot the
decompress ok and then with we also
populate different values in data frame
pandas dataframe for plotting purposes
later
so this is these are the results for
this small benchmark okay these are the
results for the arranged linear
distribution linear space lead which is
a linear distribution to and this is the
random distribution okay and these are
the different compressor that that are
included in block itself okay here we
have the times for compressing and
decompressing okay and here we have the
compression ratio the compression ratio
are really amazing this is not this is
not a bath in this light this is real
okay if you las uses a technique which
is called shuffling that it's works very
well in order to compress regular
distributions like this one it does the
chaplain doesn't work very well in case
of random distribution this is why in
random distribution we don't have this
high compression ratios okay sorry let's
say that's a good question so they're
random ok he only lost from 0 to 1,000
and the integers is 8 byte integers so
the the hackers but the the most
significant bites of these integers at
many zeros this is why you can reach if
everything is completely random it's
it's important it's impossible to
compress everything anything right okay
so here we just plot the different
speeds using pandas with the data frame
we build a data frame okay and we are
plotting for the list for the different
data distributions we can see the
different speeds so the first bars are
men cpy okay so this is the speed of the
mem cpy and in the my laptop this is
around six gigabytes per second which is
pretty typical modern laptops
and this are the different compressors
in the speed of different compressors in
block so for this arranged linear
distribution we can see that block else
it can be can be actually faster then
there is LCD for that can be even faster
and blah scales it else it h4h see it's
a hike compressor mode of the same
compressor than LCD for and they share
the same colic okay but they they are
meant more to spend more time
compressing and they can achieve better
compression ratios but still that the
compression ratio can be faster than men
cpy which is interesting glossy also has
support for his nap in which doesn't
reach the performance of MEMS Eby and
also has support for the lip in case
people prefers more compression ratios
unless a speed ok this is support of
course at lip it's a it's much lower
than the mCP why so this is for the
arranged linear distribution for linear
space the things are not so clear for
example blood elves it doesn't reach the
performance on of men cpy but else it
for not for compression but for the
compression can decompress data faster
than mm cpy which is an interesting
thing even else it for high compression
can they compress faster it takes a lot
of time to compress but can decompress
like this very fast okay so as snappy
doesn't reach but it's is also very good
and then sell lip which is meant for
better compression ratios instead of a
speed here it is the random distribution
it's a pattern similar to the to the
other one and we can see that the only
the compressor that can beat actually
mem cpy is Elsa for ok into the
compression it can go like one mega one
gigabyte per second faster no one half a
gigabyte per second faster ok so yeah it
is it is possible on a variety of
mr. emotions to beat to beat minn cpy I
encourage you to try to reproduce your
these results in your own laptops with
the materials okay so we have a couple
of open questions now first one is if
compression takes way more CPU that
meant cpy because men cpy is not in
distress in the CPU at all why is
compressing use more CPU like I'm blask
be faster than the main cpy this is the
first question and the second question
is this data is completely synthetic
okay what happens when the data is not
synthetic and it's real life data okay
so we need to to answer these two
questions first of all I am going to
splain why blask can beat mem cpy so for
that I need to expose first what i want
what i like to call the starving cpu
problem and richer sites has a nice
article which was written in 1996 i
think it's worth to mention it and in
this article which a sax is one of the
fathers of micro processors and is the
actual architect of the Alpha processor
in the in the 90s across the industry
today's chips are largely able to
execute code faster than we can feed
them with instructions and data and that
was set almost 20 years ago so what
happened in during these 20 years and
the 20 years ago cpus or were already
faster way faster than memory so here's
the dependence between the evolution of
the speed of memory in red and also
devolution in the speed of CPUs
okay in green light in the green line we
can see that the gap between these two
speeds are the gap is opening okay and
growing and there is no site that this
gap is going to stop increasing okay
this blue line means the correction
because around 2005 the vendors started
to introduce multi-course in processors
okay so the blue line is the correction
of the speed by adding multiple cores
multiple cores can do more instructions
in the same frequency right so the
frequency stalled but the effective
speed continues to grow so this is a
tendency that there is no science to
stop the problem is so evident that
people is not right in small sections in
blogs is not writing articles is writing
in tight books about the problem okay
and this is a an example which I like to
cite because the the the title is so
explicit so is the memory system you
can't avoid it you can ignore it you can
fake it many times where only focused on
cpu speeds but memory speed is
tremendously important nowadays so this
is the situation now in 2014 memory
latency is much as lower than processors
around a factor of 100 and 250 times
slower which is a lot that means that
when a cpu asked for a data that it's
not in cash the CPU has to wait and sit
and do nothing for 100 or 250 cycles and
that's a lot of waiting okay memory
bandwidth is different it's improving at
a better rate than Ratan Singh but it is
it is still also slower than processors
between a factor of 30 and 100 okay so
even if if men cpy is bringing
data at full speed of the memory masses
the CPU can could even do 30 times or
100 times more things with with the data
had to wait a lot while the weight is
arriving so that main thing about blog
is why CPUs had to be waiting for data
and doing nothing so they they are plus
is to do compression okay instead of
making the CPUs to wait compression and
decompression so this is the goal of
Lusk the gallows blocks case for example
if we have our data sets in memory here
instead of having the data set
decompressed in memory having to
transfer the data set to the gaseous why
not having the data set compressed in
memory and transmit the data set to the
cash and they compress it in the cache
which is much play faster okay and in
particular this the time that it takes
to transmit the compressed block into
the cache and they compress it the sum
of these times can be smaller than this
time so the goal is a block is making
these two x being less and this time
okay I which we have seen that we are
going to to achieve this this goal yeah
yes exactly the idea is that you have to
store your data in blocks in small
blocks so that you can transfer the
blocks into the cache but of course the
box need to fit in the English aidan l1
cache or l2 cache okay what is designed
the lowest compression ratios works on
l1 but the bigger compression ratios
works on l2 sizes typical yeah
so brusque is taking advantage of this
huge memory and cpu gap and in block is
meant to discover redundancy in data as
fast as possible it comes as i said
before with a series of us compressors
like blah scale seat i'll sit for a
snappy else it for high compression and
the lip and of course Brask is meant for
speed and not for achieving high
compression ratios high compression
ratios are meant for other kind of
compressors work is all about efficiency
it uses data block that fits in l1 or l2
caches as i said before so that provides
better speed up but of course less
compression ratios it's very important
it uses multithreading by default every
nowadays all the CPUs comes with several
cars so while you are going to have
different course without doing nothing
ok so multi threading is activated by
default and then it uses the shuffle
filter that I mentioned before uses the
single instruction multiple data in
Intel processors let's sse2 in all
modern intel and AMD processors no Alex
ok so these are the key reasons why
blusky so so efficient another reason is
that blass works as I was as Ian was
asking by splitting the big data sets in
small blocks ok these blocks are
transferred to to this to the cache
compress there and then they are stored
in what is called a block container ok
so in theory you can store instead of
your story it's fine your data the
compressed in these original data sets
containers you can store them in block
containers
so let me talk a little bit about
shuffling the filter that allows the
compressor to compress much more
efficiently so the principle of
shuffling it's a is relatively easy to
understand realize that we have for
example for a integers here 130 510 and
25 ok this is the binary and hexadecimal
representation in memory ok here so what
does the chaplain is that it puts the
most significant bits of the less
significant bits of these four integers
together in the same area ok
sequentially aligned the second bite
they are put here in another part the
third bite here and the last bite here
so now realize for the compressor what
is what is much more efficient to
compress this data this binary stream
here of this binary stream here in this
case it of course the compressors
normally tends to run faster and to get
better compression ratios in this in
this distribution because for example in
this case we have here a run of nine
bikes which are zeros and this is
extremely efficient to compress ok so
this is the rationale behind shuffle and
shuffle is as I said before is using ss2
for maximum speed this is one Cabot
although is that the shuffling usually
produces better compression ratios with
numerical data except when it doesn't do
that ok so my advice is always check if
shuffling which is active active active
by default is actually the compression
is actually giving you better
compression ratios
cause if not there is no sense merchants
in using it okay we will see an example
later on this is also a demonstration of
how blazquez speed is going to benefit
to the advances in CPUs in the time to
come so this is the performance this is
in the compression ratio and this is the
speed okay in megabytes per second in a
laptop which is nine years old okay and
here we have the men cpy speed which was
around 33 300 megabytes per second but
the speed of block was not very good
compared with men cpy and of course this
was using only one thread by that time
not many processors had multi-course
this is the same plot but using a
desktop computer two years old okay this
it is pretty usual this this desktop has
a cpu with six cores sticks physical
cores 12 threads ok and this is the
speed of mem cpy to around six gigabytes
per second and here this is the
decompression speed so we can see that
the compassionate speed using 646 course
can be like I don't know probably four
times faster than named zippy why ok so
just compare CPUs of almost ten years
ago I CPUs of two years ago and this
tendance is going to grow ok this is
this speeds are going the difference
between men zby and unblock the
compression speed is going to primp roof
with it
so I think we already have some hints
for answering the first question okay
the fifth question was why bloss can be
faster than mcp-1 well we have seen that
block and data blocking optimizes the
cache behavior doona memory access this
is very important it uses multithreading
and simple instruction multiple data
structures and if we add these to the
turbid start CPU problem we can now
figure out why blocks can be faster than
mcp why okay so this is the first answer
and then two other the second question
is how does work that in real life okay
so let me show you an example of that so
compressions of course allows to stow
allows to store more data using the same
storage capacity but of course it uses
more CPU time to compress and decompress
data but the question is that that if
you see more CPU means actually more
wall time okay these are different
concepts you can use a lot of CPU but
maybe wall times are are smaller okay
and for this we also in the real world
we need a compressed container it is
this this is very important so
compressed container is meant to store
data in a compressed State and
transparently deliver it uncompressed to
the user Oh to the CPU at least maybe
the user doesn't see the compressed
memory the compressed data and that
means that the you said only perceives
that care dataset takes less memory okay
but not only lesser space but we want to
know what happens with the with the data
access speed okay
here it is an X our first example on how
blocks can accelerate things in genomics
for example doing io in genomics okay so
there is a a guy which called the mark
how is on that made a sick with TB which
is a format and a library to do input
output and to do queries in genomics
okay and see it happens that sick sick
dabei vb is is baked by borsk okay so
here is the speed of mem cpy intro in
red and here is the speed in red in
black the mem cpy and in red the speed
of chick DB which is bike baked by my
boss so this is a first example real
data where blood can actually accelerate
things okay this data is published in
this article here second example blows
back 10 minutes okay thank you so brass
back is a command-line interface and
civilization format for blush okay the
author it's Valentin channel which is
sitting there so thank you for your
effort doing that so usually it is very
simple for example realize that you have
data setting on the on disk so
compressing it is just a matter of using
the command line using the sea for
compressing and for the compression is
using a day under the compound on the
compress on the con they compress the
file also a blast pack allows for a very
convenient way to sterilize in memory
non PI data sets okay so if we have an
example a dataset know by data set like
this one here we can say that I see two
discs by use block backpack and the
array file we pass the array and
therefore the file okay
and then we can decide allies the file
by using unpack and the array file and
then we get the be the digitalized data
and if we check that amb is our equals
it is of course block package using
blocks behind the scenes so this happens
very high speed probably this is one of
the fastest ways to serialize empire
race normal is yet another example bliss
so bliss is both a format and a library
that has been designed physician
efficiency data container for bit data
as I said before we're using it as a
place as a backing for the word blaze
innocent blaze library and blah scam
plus pack are at the heart of the
library in order to achieve high
compression high-speed compression and
the compression okay so i am going to
skip because i am running out of time at
five minutes now okay so basically bliss
is meant to store data all data detect
that data contain data that can be
opened only not modified it's especially
address to this to the situation and
then achieve that for by use instead of
using monolithic data contains like noon
pile it uses chunked compact containers
okay so this can be enlarged very pretty
easily because you don't need a copy in
order to copy you can keep the chunks
and when you whenever you add in are
adding new new data we just have to
compress the new data and you get the
finer content very fast
and also there is a beatable object BL
seat that its column the storage is
columnar so you can add new rows very
easily and the chunks are sorted by
columns ok doing that by columns has a
lot of advantages in many situations I'm
not going to enter into the details but
for example especially for Queen when
you have tables with a large amount of
columns normal eco a culinary storage is
mine is more efficient so let me show
you some brief numbers
okay I am NOT going to discuss
everything because we don't have time
but you are invited to look at the
notebook which is included in the
materials just have a look at the at the
size of a data frame for example for
storing this is data market in the store
market to the pollution of Microsoft in
one single day so that generates light
around to help a mega gigabytes of
information okay in a in a pandas
dataframe if we are using bliss to start
it in memory because this supports both
in memory and on disk storage we can see
that using several compressors we are
the I was having I was experimenting
with different compressors and
activating and deactivating shuffle but
you can see that this almost half
gigabyte can be reduced to 26 megabytes
this is this is not fake this is real
data okay it happens that in general in
reality a lot of data that comes in
finance our names are not not available
okay because you need to align different
different columns and you went with a
huge number of noms these names are very
easily compressible okay so this is why
we can reach these compression ratios
here by playing with different
processors with different compressors we
can reach 20 megabytes and even using
the hitch or the jet lip okay with Kai
gas compression ratio we can reach 10
megabytes that means 40 x 40 times
smaller than the original data frame
that's very nice but we want to see if
that really
behaves well if we are losing a lot of
speed on that here is the typical way to
query data in bliss ok so in this case
using the set lip with the maximum
compression we are using 100
milliseconds for doing this query and
using using pandas we can get 4014
milliseconds ok so bliss is much lower
but bliss in this case is using the
slowest compression what happens it
please can use the fastest compressor so
with fastest compressor the time goes
down from 100 to 27 milliseconds and and
pandas is taking 14 that means only a
factor of two not that much ok and there
is another thing is that in bliss I has
not been I have not been able to use
multithreading while while doing the
queries so this is still a work in
progress ok I am pretty sure if I can't
use I can start using multiprocessing in
this in this part here we can reach very
close x than panels for example ok
one minute ok so we here we have the
second hint for the point questions
bloss usage in Belize for example means
not only less a storage but also this
almost the same time access then than
the data ok for example than pandas
which is very heavy eyes for doing
queries but they still need to address
this implementation details for getting
better performance so in summary bloss
being able to transfer data faster than
mcp why has in my opinion enormous
implications in data on the data
management ok implication that we cannot
ignore its own not only well suited for
saving memory but all for allowing
closed performant to typical and
compressed data containers and it works
well not only for synthetic data but
also for real life datasets that's I
said before you have the reference for
all the projects all the projects are
open source so you can download it you
can modify them and you can send us to
Valentina me pull request very very
welcomed so I will finish with citing
Richard sites again in this article
we're finally in the article he said
that over the coming decade memory
subsystem design will be the only
important design issue for micro
processors that was said 20 years ago ok
so the coming decade was the previous
decade and I am saying that in this
decade memory subsystem motivation will
almost be there all important design
issue for improving performance but this
is my opinion
okay cool thank you very much